what do we think apples music service is
really going to look like well it's kind
of these stitched together think of a
bunch of different services that they
have their the itunes download service
they bought beats music for three
billion dollars so it's going to be a
kind of thing where you pay ten bucks a
month and you can listen to as much
music as you want the question is
whether or not they're going to be doing
anything here that's really particularly
different than what's already available
Apple's coming really late to the market
compared to some other services like
Spotify and so there's a lot of
questions around what's gonna be the
differentiator but Apple has never ever
been a copycat in anything they do so
couldn't one expect if they're going to
get in this game they're gonna do at
apple style which is big they're
definitely a dude big this is expected
to be a big marketing budget around it
I'm sure they're gonna get some some big
name artists to come out if you remember
they've done a lot of things with you
two over the years and so you expect
them to get some big name artists to
help them push it but that's that
doesn't mean it's gonna work jay-z just
rolled out his a new streaming service
called title with seemed like every
artist imaginable and that hasn't gotten
anywhere as well so it's a very
competitive market and so it's simply
something that they're gonna have to
scratch and claw it Adam music is going
to get the lion's share of media
attention but software is a big deal of
this year's WWDC right I mean in the
grand scheme of things music it is not a
big part of apples overall business
anymore what perhaps would be more
important is there going to be giving
all these software tools to developers
to be making apps for the Apple watch
Apple hasn't said how the watch is
selling yet but being able to have some
good applications on
is going to be a key to his long-term
success and developers yet haven't had
the same sort of access to the device to
be able to fill the different kind of
tools that you have on an iPhone that
you could have on the watch there you go
I don't know do you don't have an iWatch
my husband does he answered the phone
yesterday on his watch whose sole aim
seriously it was lame Dick Tracy it's
nerdy alright Adam thank you so much
Adam satariano from the Apple developers
conference in San Francisco